hey guys Pete here HBO Spain dropped a
brand new trailer for Game of Thrones
Season seven so we're going to look at
that then I'm going to come back back
and break it down it's not quite as
elaborate as the one that we saw for the
primary HBO trailer but they're all new
scenes and there's some pretty cool
stuff you want to see something you've
never seen before
promise you won't tell anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just today's wals don't matter the north
needs to bound together
[Music]
happy now close the door
[Music]
I'm going to do this breakdown in the
most spoiler-free way I know how we know
what a lot of the stuff relates to from
monitoring set shots and different
things that leaked out during the early
going of filming but I'm going to keep
all that out of this video so we're just
going to talk about what we see alright
so we start off with a shot of a clapper
board and we can see that they are
shooting episode 2 of season 7 which is
directed by Mark Malad the scene takes
place in the citadel and we have a
maester or more likely in archmaester
looking at a book the face is obscured
so could be just pretty much anyone it
could be jim broadbent who is rumored to
play archmaester a Broce it doesn't
really look like it fits that
description
a bros has like a little mask and a
silver staff and the books anyways that
doesn't mean that you will the show but
we also know that Philippa
O'Sullivan was cast as a maester and
frankly what seems in the Citadel there
should be lots of these guys roaming
around so we really don't know who it is
in the next shot we see the unsullied
charging the Lannister army on their
home turf or at least that's what we
think because we see lannister sigils in
the background and I think it's a pretty
safe bet that this is Casterly Rock then
we see a shot of Daenerys standing back
up after touching the Westerosi sand
below Dragonstone we've seen quite a few
shots of her here from the HBO photos so
it's not likely to be anywhere else
after that we see leonard lannister
archers firing off their arrows and what
looks like jamie back there on the white
horse behind them we see jamie later so
that's what makes me think this is him
but you can really can't tell it's from
a battle that occurs in an open field
which i won't spoil any details about
but i will say that this is a different
battle from the first shots we saw with
the unsullied next scene is related and
we watch as Lannister's get roasted baba
looks like dragon flame in the first
shot we see the crew nearby with their
frog man who kind of suits and fire
extinguished
then we get a shot of the mountain and
his brand new Dark Kingsguard armor
drawing his sword so I guess this
indicates that he can still do more than
just smash people's heads there's a
behind the scene shot in the dragon
stone throne room and Emilia Clarke
makes a funny face for us we can see
that all her peeps are their prey worm a
sandy varus and Tyrion next we see Jaime
making his new trademark face it looks
like he's in King's Landing
probably in the red key and maybe in the
Queen's chambers which we'll see in a
minute but anyways Jaime looks on easy
to borderline upset which is how he
pretty much always looks since his
sister has taken the throne look at a
quick shot of Jon Snow sort of juggling
his sword he's wearing skin similar to
what we saw in the batch of promo photos
where he's running with torment my guess
here is that this is north of the wall
because he's wearing such heavy winter
gear similar to what he did back in his
wildling period a few seasons back
there's a shot of an unsullied fighter
falling from a ladder outside but looks
like the same Casterly Rock stuff we saw
earlier and at this point we hear the
first and only words of the trailer
start they come from the king in the
north
himself and we see him addressing the
entire gang in the Great Hall of
Winterfell he says yesterday's Wars
don't matter the neat North needs to
band together and when I say the whole
gang it is just that if you look at the
shot you can pick out just about
everyone related to the northern houses
plus a few wildlings
John has Davos and Sansa at his side and
we can only imagine that this would have
to be about the threat from the north we
get a really quick shot of a fight on
the deck of the ship that can't make out
who's involved Theon or you're on or
both would be the most likely candidate
since it appears to be for men there but
you know anyone's guesses good here
I have no idea see a monitor shot of
Daenerys running her fingers over the
mat table at Dragonstone where we used
to see Stannis hanging out back in the
day
quick shot amazing Williams behind the
scenes flashing a smile the crew look to
be bundled up for winter and based on
other photos we've seen from HBO I'm
gonna take a wild guess and say that
this is from somewhere between the
Riverlands and Winterfell after that we
get a shot of Daenerys with a torch
exploring what could be best described
as an underground place I'm not sure
where this is but it brings to mind
Stannis having a conversation with John
telling him that there was dragonglass
all over the place near Dragonstone
that's a paraphrase obviously but this
looks like it might be a cavern to me
but we'll just leave it at that because
it could be underneath Dragonstone like
in some Crips or the dungeons who knows
really the next thing we see is almost
miscible the way that it is cut but it
looks like it's some tightening up our
techniques related to dragon fire that
they're filming in the studio it should
be no great secret there lots of stuff
is going to get burned and it looks like
the crew is getting ready to do that on
film and we see grey worm playing around
with the guy whose throat he might be
getting ready to split once they start
shooting again then we see Daenerys
walking into her new throne room again
this is at Dragonstone we know that for
sure we see our other Queen Queen Cersei
it looks like her bedchamber and this is
actually the only shot of her that we
get in this trailer there's a close-up
of sophie Turner in full sanso mode up
in Winterfell then we see Podrick and
Brienne sparring in the yard it's good
to see that they're picking up on his
training and it looks like she's going
full speed like she's really giving him
a go they're not a hundred percent sure
what this next thing is we can see
they're lighting something on fire could
just be like a torch
you know the crew
it looks like the crews doing it because
there's a modern he has a modern device
there they lighting it with so it's
probably just something for the
background but if you have a better idea
of what this is let me know in the
comments we get a nice behind-the-scenes
shot of the Hound in the studio he seems
happy to smile for the camera but not
sure there's anything else important
going on here looks like one of the
people from wardrobe is getting and
ready to shoot something we see Daenerys
and her entourage moving and it has the
fields I'm going to meet someone since
they're all together like that but no
concrete evidence to say what's going on
here it's a quick shot of the crew and
it looks pretty cool it looks like
they're in a field that absolutely looks
scorched I'm not sure if they're putting
stuff out or if they're putting smoke
out to make it look that way but it's a
nice shot we see an unsullied breaking
or slashing a lannister neck from that
same battle from earlier and a cool shot
of Jamie mounted riding into battle on
horseback
these troops they're around him we can
see there's a road there with the wagon
that looks like it's carrying supplies
and people are moving in different
directions
I'll leave the spoilers out of this but
yeah that looks like a pretty cool shot
then we have an alternate angle of the
unsullied rush at Casterly Rock then we
see this dropping of a Lannister banner
which could be like a behind-the-scenes
thing or I'm not sure but there's also
this wooden box underneath and there's a
piece of gaffers tape on it that looks
like it says Alana to me so you know
that would be the queen of thorns it
could be a hint or it could just be
there I mean it seems pretty on purpose
so that could be a hint of foreshadowing
that the Lannister lion will be showing
it Highgarden since that's their home
base so the Tyrells home base so who
knows after that it closes with Arya
coming back to tell the visitors goodbye
and that is that so it's an interesting
trailer I think that most of this stuff
or at least a lot of this stuff is going
to be in the early episodes
I'm not a hundred percent sure about the
battle stuff but you could tell like
it's heavy on the Dragonstone stuff sort
of you know Daenerys we seized an arrow
sort of getting there and moving in
there whatever you want to say so that's
all likely to happen early on John is in
the North addressing the houses there so
yeah I think most of the stuff is early
season stuff like I said we see two
separate battles here well three if you
count the fight on the deck if you're
interested in spoilers about that kind
of stuff you can check out my spoilers
playlist we talk about a lot of these
scenes when they were shooting them
initially but if your damn spoiler free
I can respect that and I won't go into
it here but tell me what you guys think
this is a pretty cool installation they
had over in Spain are you bummed out
that we haven't seen something similar
in the States what are you most excited
about out of these clips and what do you
hope to see in relation to the early
episodes in season seven please like the
video if you enjoyed it leave any
questions in the comments and please
subscribe to my channel because there's
plenty more Game of Thrones stuff to
come thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon